et
être un menteur et il changer le monde
ayant pris conscience à peu près à
l'adolescence par là à quel point le
monde pourrait être un parfait est loin
de cet idéal vers lequel on aimerait
qu'il tombe d'ailleurs si vous
connaissez la différence entre un
utopiste un idéaliste l'utopie nous
avons parlé d'un monde qui n'existe pas
l'italie doivent montrer le chemin pour
l'atteindre
et c'est une réalité qu'il est toujours
bon de rappeler que nous vivions dans un
monde fini ressources limitées et quand
on met en relation l'accroissement de la
population le développement de la
civilisation et l'épuisement des
ressources
malheureusement tôt ou tard tout
croissance au film est infinie on arrive
vers le fameux lieu à mâcon crédit
depuis l'enfant en l'occurrence vers
2030 nous reste donc à peu près 16 ans
pour encore essayer de changer les
choses
ce qui est intéressant sur cette pauvre
c'est que c'est un extrait d'une étude
qui a été faite dans les années 70 un
groupe de chercheurs américains
c'est de voir les deux la croissance
rapports qui sont faits prédisait pas
leurs scénarii possibles et il ya deux
ans du pour les 40 ans de ces études là
ils sont usés a comparé 40 ans de
données factuelles avec leur première
prédiction et ce qui est quelque part
l'inquiétant c'est finalement en 40 ans
ça défile scénario de l'effondrement
c'est à dire que vers 2030 2035
il y avoit terrible mais pas mal de
bouleversements
c'est aussi l'occasion d'essayer de
changer pas mal de choses du moins de
construire le fda relative aux systèmes
qui existent actuellement
j'ai toujours dire c'est pas là ça va
être la fin du monde après ça sera bien
la fin d'un monde et ce qu'il faut aussi
réaliser c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya déjà
des alternatives qui sont en train
d'être mise en place d'être construit
tout simplement en prendre conscience et
faire ce qu'on peut pour les favoriser
pour justement que se développent et
puis
peut-être contribué à un remplacement du
modèle général actuel cette prise de
conscience celui finalement assez tôt
mais il ya aussi cette impuissance à se
dire concrètement comment on comment
agir comment faire quelque chose surtout
pendant les études que j'ai sur une fine
vous avez bien fait prendre conscience
de cette responsabilité quand la vanille
quand on conçoit un objet au prix mal
conçu c'est comme mettre tout de suite
un déchet sur le marché c'est non
seulement pas intéressant mais c'est
même un gaspillage de ressources
alors finalement comment en ayant cette
responsabilité comment faire quelque
chose et à ce moment là bas une piste
commence à émerger
c'est justement la roue de l'époque et
un homme formidable c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on a l'occasion de résoudre des vieux
paradoxe c'est à dire qu'on peut agir
localement à petite échelle tout en
étant ouvert et reliques connecter au
reste du monde
alors grâce essentiellement à internet
puisqu'il fait qu'on va voir agir en se
concertant et avoir un impact global
quand même conséquent alors armé un peu
de cette nouvelle certifier que je me
demandais vous concrètement comment mes
serveurs et là c'est là où justement il
ya plein de tendance qui émerge
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils vont converger et
gagnent une non identifiés comme hub mal
sur lui sur un brin du moins pas essayer
de progresser dans cette voie c'est tout
ce qu'on va appeler les fablabs hacker
space m'écoeure space des lieux dans
lesquels les gens vont se réunir pour
faire des choses alors ça peut être des
choses plus ou moins compliqué tout et
n'importe quoi peut-être la cuisine de
la couture elle aussi pourquoi pas un
séquençage de l'adn des voitures et
maisons
potentiellement il n'y a pas de grands
défis qu on puisse résoudre avec de
petits efforts mis en commun et si l'âne
bien cette photo
parce qu'en fait à l'époque je m'étais
dis moi mon job le rsa sera peut-être de
travailler dans l'instable comme ça
directement au service tout
en public lors de concevoir un objet
pour une entreprise qui va le fabriqué
en espagne le plan devra déjà essayé de
travailler directement au service des
gens et les aider à concevoir leurs
propres solutions
un peu les mettre en capacité de faire
des choses et en l'occurrence
malheureusement il ya pas de fab lab à
l'époque annonce il y en avait un à
toulouse mais se développait c'était
seulement le démarrage de ça on va dire
non en europe qu'à cela ne tienne on a
monté avec des amis en réunissant
seulement très peu de moyens avec une
centaine d'euros par an il est quelques
membres en détail on a pu finalement
retaper un bâtiment ce faire notre
propre local et là où cette communauté
qui s'est formée à ce moment là est très
dynamique
c'est que là pour l'anecdote on a une
fenêtre ni chauffage pendant qu'annie
vérifier 8,2 les gens reviennent
pourtant chaque semaine parce que bâle
se partagent cette mise en commun et
aujourd'hui on construit comme ça
de plus en plus par le monde il ya plus
de 6000 espace crise dont deux semaines
plusieurs principes mais dans le calme
finalement l'histoire commence en
parallèle d'un petit peu gros quand j'ai
construit une des premières imprimantes
3d en france grâce à l'élan qui étaient
disponibles sur internet
ce genre de machine qu'on va justement
trouvé dans ses dehors ça peut être et
découpe laser traceur des fraiseuses mu
alors qu'aujourd'hui on en parle souvent
de plus en plus de celle ci que parce
que n y change un peu la manière de
collecter des choses c'est à dire que
plutôt que de tailler dans un bloc de
matière on va ajouter progressivement
des couches de matière s'il ya
permettent de fabriquer notamment des
assemblages qu'on ne saurait pas faire
autrement bien que là c'est une pièce
qui a été fait d'un seul bloc en une
seule fois
ils s'étaient déjà assemblés pendant la
fabrication alors je passerai sur cette
technologie elle est peut-être
fascinante
mais le plus intéressant finalement
c'est comment aujourd'hui elle devient
accessible
c'est à dire que il ya peut-être 30 ans
l' impression de 3d ça faisait ses
débuts mais aujourd'hui elle devient
accessible grâce notamment aux projets
redrado qui va permettre en fait c'est
une initiative de chercheurs anglais qui
ont réinventé
mais là où leurs idées c'est génial
c'est qu'ils ont faim en open source
peut donc commencer la recherche presque
un brevet est tombé dans le domaine du
don qu'il pouvait pas aller sans papiers
en refaire un autre projet mais plutôt
que d'essayer de verrouiller les
connaissances ils les ont contraire
partager et en les partageant ils ont
permis à plein d'autres gens comme moi
de refabriquer cette machine vannes qui
permet à la fois de valider le concept
c'est pas un coup de chance on arrive à
être le répliquer plusieurs fois et en
même temps ça des conséquences assez au
fond de l'enceinte où vous allez donner
aux gens un accès à des mois une
production avec un capital très faible
suffit d'investir finalement dans le cas
c'était à peu près six mois 700 euros et
j'avais sur mon bureau cette formidable
machine it in hybrid fabriqué il va mais
premier des objets alors une fois que
c'était super performant mais les choses
s'améliorent et comme c'est une des
premières machines
finalement j'ai été amené à être
enthousiasmants parler à d'autres
personnes à les aider à construire leur
propre machine et ce faisant le déplacer
avec leur ses pairs à pratiquer du tout
c'était du lourd en france à peu près 7
kg à bout de bras comme ça ce n 5 bat du
coup ça m'a amené à créer cette machine
là la folle d'art alors quel avantage
d'être client pour pour la transporter
partout
du coup il était dérivée du premier
projet mais c'est ça qui est formidable
c'est comme tout est ouvert
chacun va pouvoir l'adapter à ses
problèmes on voit ses ressources
certains vont faire des machines avec
les composants qui trouve à côté de chez
eux moi mon problème c'était comment
seront transportés a facilement les
invendus cliente est plus facile à
transporter et je me suis retrouvé à
faire encore plus de conférences de
démonstration et là on va dire ya un
autre problème et carrick une machine ce
n'est peut-être faire 700 euros mois et
jean-talon contenu de la mettre au point
de l'améliorer donc fermés dont une
dizaine de prototypes sept niveaux ça
commence à me faire un peu cher pour un
étudiant dans sa chambre et en même
temps le fait de l'avoir montrée afin de
personnes je savais qu'ils étaient
intéressés pour pour soit
potentiellement en acheter c'est
aujourd'hui et le fait qu'ils sont en
train devenir complètement banale mais
qui
justement sont assez puissantes c'est
plutôt que d'aller voir un banquier en
lui disant voilà mon projet j'ai tant de
clients aussi mon business model j'ai
directement mis ça sur une seule
plateforme de financement participatif
en disant non plus à quelqu'un une sorte
d'intermédiaire mais directement aux
futurs utilisateurs
s'ils ont pris dans ce projet là mais
fameux dix prototypes que je fais selon
le lag la hauteur du don vous m'envoyer
en contrepartie par jour avec un clip
pour que vous puissiez fabriquer votre
propre machine et donc ça s'est fait de
mieux sur ce genre de plateforme c'est
qu'il ya un budget minimum sans quoi le
projet n'est pas validé et chacun va
paraître samedi
donc ça c'est aussi un peu étude de
marché il ya peu de risques à prendre il
n'y a pas de plafond maximum et en
général quand une bonne idée rencontre
un certain succès beaucoup de gens donc
ça peut intéresser beaucoup de personnes
et sur mes 10 premiers prototypes en
fait nous surtout être avancée à 30
j'ai même un m'ont dit stop parce que
au-delà dans ma chambre des finances
avait bataillé et finalement ça a été
trop bien marché alors c'était super
parce que ça permet de voir non
seulement le processus était ouvert le
résultat tout était open source mais
même le financement est un peu différent
il était cette fois distribué sur un
ensemble de vent et du coup l'année la
fin d'avril ça on a fait un autre
campagne de financement
toutefois des anglais j'étais capable
d'en faire trente noms des pour 30 ou
s'y trouvaient à bord dans 400 alors ça
pose d'autres problèmes dans le temps
c'est sympa parce que vous retrouvez
jeune auto entrepreneur mais en même
temps multinationales les machines un
peu partout dans le monde jusqu'au japon
en afrique côte ouest des états unis
mais il ya un autre problème qui se pose
c'est comment êtes vous passé à une
échelle supérieure et c'est là où chaque
projet est toujours l'occasion
d'expérimenter d'autres voies d'autres
alternatives la plupart du temps pour
d'autres constructeurs on m'a dit un
petit souvenir d'un plan d'aidé qui
passe à une autre échelle
il revenait sur des procédés
traditionnels plus adapté à la grande
scène mais on perd la caractéristique
propre
des deux c'est la crainte de ses
imprimantes 3d vous en faites les
machines sont composés de pièces un
piment très bien il faut que vous en
aviez nous pouvons produire d'autres
donc concrètement dans ma chambre qu'on
avait
de droit qui tournait pour fabriquer
d'autres machines mais je voulais pas
monter une usine de la trappe conformité
de la trappe c'était un peu paradoxal je
n'ai pas la place nous la motivation de
frappe lorsque j'ai fait la place
c'est finalement je me suis réabonné
c'est aux premières personnes qui
avaient déjà une imprimante prenez en
leur disant 20 tous ensemble sont
distribués cette production surtout ceux
qui pourtant seulement une machine c'est
comme si on avait une usine ans et vous
non seulement on distribue quelques
tables de travail la fabrication mais ça
parle aussi de rendre un peu à cette
communauté alors non seulement la
machine open source sont quelque part
j'ai pu la tuer grâce à des
connaissances qui avait été partagée
alors de manière réciproque je vais
faire partager toutes les connaissances
que moi j'ai développé pour cette
machine est la même c'est le profil
lui-même qui va distribuer sur la connu
encourageants du coup ce projet là et
c'est assez intéressant parce que tout
accompagné toute une dynamique qui se
met en place et il ya des gens qui vont
pouvoir
même s'ils ont remboursé leurs premières
machines et ses faux airs à saint
affrique toujours de dire ben mes
clients sont devenus nos fournisseurs
les prochains bilans et défendant bien
cette peur cette courbe
là où c'est un très intéressant via les
fables appeler hacker space qui sont
répartis dans le monde entier d'avoir
cette logique de fabrication distribués
c'est que faut savoir qu'en fait il ya
de votre fois plus de ressources qui
sont utilisés uniquement pour
transporter des biens et des produits
que pour les fabriquer donc
potentiellement à cause de tout le
circuit logistique
potentiellement si on fabriquait les
choses soi-même ou faisant appel à
d'autres personnes ne serait-ce que plus
localement y aurait moyen d'économiser
énormément de ressources et si vous
raconte tout ça ça peut sembler une
expérience incroyable mais faut que vous
ayez conscience que mon cas n'est pas
unique
on est des dizaines des centaines
d'ennemis lui travailler comme ça avant
de dire à peu près à construire des
alternatives pour un autre monde
et si jamais vous même vous doutiez vous
pensez que tout est trop petit pour
changer quoi que ce soit essayez de
dormir avec un moustique enfants